et toi Serge qu'est-ce que tu préfères
aller à l'école ou conduire un tracteur
conduire un tracteur tu ne regrettes pas
de ne pas être en 6e
non la rentrée scolaire vient de raviver
les problèmes crise de locaux comme dans
cette école exigu de Paris mais surtout
manque de maîtrre manque de professeurs
de l'aggravement de cette crise et de
ces manques on accuse volontiers la
réforme de l'enseignement qui exige
davantage de classe et beaucoup plus
d'enseignants elle en exige en effet
mais elle en exigera bien davantage
l'année prochaine sielle est entièrement
appliqué cela vaut-il la peine oui car
si on lui donne les moyens de réussir
cette réforme risque de doubler le
capital intellectuel culturel et
technique de la France c'est un risque à
courir non une expérience faite cette
année dans le Loiré montre ce qui doit
être réalisé dans toute la France il
vous faudra donc
transposer il vous faudra remplacer
Orléan par Paris Pitivier par Marseille
montargie par Lyon et Bazoche les
galerand par roubet ou tourcoin dans le
Loiret cette année 7000 enfants ont
lâche des 36e sur ces 7000 enfants 2500
étaient candidat à l'entré en 6e 4500 ne
l'était pas on a voulu savoir et c'est
cela qui est nouveau si parmi ces 4500
non candidats il ne s'en trouvait pas
qui fussent capable sans le savoir de
faire des études secondaires on a
examiné de près leur livret scolaire on
les a testé le résultat monsieur Humbert
directeur du centre d' tion d'Orléan
nous le donne et bien nous avons
découvert la chose absolument
ahurissante c'est de trouver de trouver
dans la nature sur ces 4500 enfants 1800
d'entre eux qui étaient des sujets
nettement ttes à bénéficier de
l'enseignement secondaire ces 1500
enfants récupérés il a fallu pour les
accueillir improviser de nouveaux
bâtiments ainsi l'école de Basoche
lesgalerand de 800 habitants possède
maintenant deux classes de 6e toute
neuve à Monsieur dufen instituteur qui
dirige cette école nous avons demandé
quels sont vos professeurs de 6e nous
avons trois professeurs qui sont-ils ces
trois professeurs sont moi-même qui
m'occupe de des mathématiques et des
sciences ainsi que de l'histoire et de
la
géographie un jeune suppléant qui nous
vient du lot c'est Monsieur Loubradou
qui s'occupe du français et qui fait
également l'éducation physique et nous
avons également madame noubradou qui
s'occupe de l'anglais les les élèves de
cette 6e de Bazoche font tous partie de
ces 1500 enfants récupérés on est allé
leur demander d'entrer en 6e il faut
donc aller les chercher sinon il ne
viendrai pas car ils habitent tous dans
des villages éloignés de Bazoche notre
cœ part le matin à 7h15 de Bazoche il
ramasse trois enfants ici un autre là
deux ici deux là il ramasse un ici TR là
qu ici un ici et rentre Basoche vers
8h le 2ème circuit ici est beaucoup plus
pauvre en élève nous avons seulement 4re
enfants le trisème circuit se compose
ici un enfant ici trois autres là un là
la jeune Monique Martin que nous prenons
ici à Grenville et à Guignonville 4re
enfants et nous revenons par ici à
Basoche pour arriver juste à 9h ce qui
fait combien de kilomètres en tout 265
km par
[Musique]
jour pour vous prouver que le ramassage
bouleverse la vie scolaire élargit
l'avenir de ces enfants nous avons
choisi l'exemple d'une bonne élève qui
vient d'entrer en 6e Monique Martin
pouvez-vous me dire Monique comment on
met en évidence que l'OS contient de la
Chau évidence qu'unos contient de la
Chau en le plongeant dans de l'acide
acétique que se passe-t-il exactement
l'os devient mou pourquoi devient-il m
parce que la partie minérale a été
détruite le père de monque Martin est
ouvrier agricole tous les soirs Monique
retourne à Grenville nous lu avons suivi
est-ce que vous auriez une photo de tous
vos enfants madame Martin non monsieur
j' pas pourquoi bon il ont jamais tous
été ensemble puis combien avez-vous 10
monsieur que font les aînés de Monique
les de Monique a qui un qui boulanger un
qui travaille là chez Monsieur Bonet un
qui est soldat en Algérie une qui est
mariée qui travaille chez
gringoiretivier son mari est gendarme de
22 à chcuterie à Paris puis les qure
dernières à
l'école quelles études ont fait les
aînés de Monique jusqu'au certificat
d'étude qu'est-ce qui vous a décidé à
faire entrer Monique en 6e à Bazoche
bien c'est parce qu'on les remassé tous
les matins parce qu'on vient la ramasser
tous les matins oui alors c'était plus
facile ça faisait moins différent des
autres de la mettre au collège et aussi
parce que vous saviez que ce serait une
bonne élève oui parce qu'end bien
l'instituteur m'a dit que qu' pouvait
suivre mais s'il n'y avait pas eu de
classe de 6e à Bazoche et s'il n'y avait
pas eu de car pour y aller cor
éphémonique cette année ser resté en
classe avec Monsieur
rult continuer comme ces sur vous l'avez
pas mise au collège à Pitivier non
pourquoi comme je vous ai dit ça fait
trop de différence avec les autres ça
fait expliquez-moi cela et bien parce
que les enfants entre eux quand il a des
petites disputes on se dit bien toi tu
es collège tu es au collège tu dois bien
savoir ça de choses qui frappent
l'enfant ça été un privilège voilà vous
n'en vouliez pas non maintenant que
Monique est en 6e que souhaitez-vous
pour elle qu'elle passe son Bach par
exemple j'avais toujours rêvé mmet
petite je pas pouroi c'est ton rêve
aussi d'être un
sut tu sais pas ce que tu veux
faire tu es la Seu du village aller en
6earrête pour
toi
autre exemple Serge lecte de chaussie
Serge je compte veux-tu te lever peux-tu
me citer des noms de Pharaon célèbrees
ramsè 2 Chéops Menes il sait qui est
menè c'est un bon élève et pourtant il
fait partie de ces 300 enfants du Loiré
dont les parents n'ont pas voulu qu'ils
entrent en 6e nous sommes allés voir son
père Monsieur le Comte votre fils est un
très bon élève un excellent élève et
pourtant vous n'avez pas voulu qu'il
entre cette année 6e à basoch
voulez-vous me dire pourquoi écoutez mon
cas est tout à fait un peu exceptionnel
j'ai perdu ma femme au mois de juin
alors je reste en fait une culture d'von
TCT avec M parents et voilà su agé dans
une soixantaine d'années alors lui comme
la culture lui plaît alevir une beaucoup
petit travau manuel je comprends que
vous ayez besoin de lui mais quand vous
pensez qu'il pourrait à coup sûr faire
de des études très brillantes est-ce que
vous ne regrettez pas pour lui de ne pas
lui donner cette chance vu maintenant la
motorisation tous les outils qu'on a
alors je pense qu'il peut perfectionner
beaucoup mieux que en 6e il conduit bien
très très très bien mieux qu'une grande
personne oh certainement il y a
certainement des personnes âgées qui se
défendent pas si bien que lui et toi
Serge qu'est-ce que tu préfères aller à
l'école ou conduire un tracteur conduire
un tracteur tu ne regrettes pas de ne
pas être en 6e non tu es sûr
oui monsieur compte paraît croire encore
que c'est de bras que manque
l'agriculture tant
pis mais venons-en au problème que cette
récupération d'élèves a posé monsieur
lapicidaa inspecteur primaire nous y
répond et bien cette année nous avons dû
importer dans la circonscription environ
90 suppléentss par conséquent il y avait
90 postes non pourvu par des titulaires
sur environ 350 classes quel âge avez-v
monsieur denardi j'ai 23 ans cette année
vous êtes inributeur suppléant suppléant
oui quel est votre salaire monsieur
denardi mais en tant que suppléant je
fais entre 41 et 42000 par mois vous
avez des indemnités et il y a des
indemnités oui don l'indemnité
journalière que l'on touche échelonné
sur 3 mois 300 francs par jour le
premier mois 200 le 2e puis 100 francs
le 3è et ensuite elle cesse indemnité de
logement indemnité de logement oui qui
varie suivant les les zones suivant les
municipalités ici combien ici ça doit
varier entre 1000 et 1500 francs par
mois je suppose vous avez trouvé un
logement je trouvé un logement oui
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est une chambre
chez des particuliers mais qui n'est pas
chauffé bien sûr combien payez-vous je
paye 45 par
mois nous avions une seconde question
imposer à monsieur l'inspecteur primaire
ces élèves qui sont en 6e à Basoche en
ce moment dans 2 ans quand feraon et
bien évidemment le choix des familles
interviendra mais il est à prévoir que
la majorité des enfants achevant le leur
cyle d'observation iront au collège de
Pitivier ou au lycée d'Orléan il y aura
de la place pour
eux ceci est une question d'accueil
évidemment du second degré
euh l'embarras même de Monsieur
l'Inspecteur nous incita à aller trouver
Monsieur le Principal du collège de
Pitivier combien d'intern avez-vous dû
refuser à la rentrée j'en ai refusé 50
votre collège peut contenir 50
pensionnaires n'est-ce pas euh tout au
moins il a été conçu pour recevoir 50
pensionnaires j'en accueille
actuellement 100 et c'est un tour de
force comment élogezv et bien les
pensionnaires que j'inscris sont
évidemment logés ici maintenant beaucoup
de pensionnaires sont également
accueillis en ville franis Mor tu es
pensionnaire interne au collège de
Pitivier et pourtant tu habites chez
Monsieur et Madame hafeuille n'estce pas
monsieur qu'est-ce que ça signifie
madame pourquoi ce garçon est chez vous
et bien voilà pourquoi sa maman a été é
pour l'inscrire au collège et donc
monsieur principal lui a répondu qu'il
n'avait pas assez de place pour le
coucher qu'elle cherche une place dans
une famille ça comme ça il est chez vous
depuis combien de temps ça va fait sa 3e
année c'est plus agréable d'être ici
pour toi que si tu étais interne non
oui Monsieur H à cause de quoi
principalement ton avis pour la
nourriture puis la libertéiture la
liberté combien d'élèves vous apportent
le ramassage chaque matin environ 120
pour les deux collèges ces élèves sont
tous demi pensionnaires ils sont demi
pensionnaire mais là encore il y a un
gros
problème lié un peu au problème de
l'internat comme je prends 100
pensionnaires c'est au détriment des
demi-pensionnaires beaucoup de
demi-pensionnaires sont obligés de
prendre leur repas de midi en ville je
propose au parents la solution suivante
ils peuvent prendre leur repas dans une
auberge voisine du collège c'est une
solution solution satisfaisante qui
arrange les familles sauf peut-être au
point de vue pécuniaire puisque cette
solution est plus onéreuse naturellement
que la demi-pension à l'école Monsieur
le Principal avez-vous assz de
professeur ah les professeurs me
manquent
malheureusement il y a une semaine
encore une de mes classes n'avait ni
professeur de mathématiques ni
professeur de lettres ni professeur
d'anglais un maître est arrivé en
mathématiques il me manque toujours un
professeur de lettres et un professur
d'anglais même problème au collège de
montargie où tenteront d'entrer les
élèves de Bazoche orientés vers le
technique la question ici comment
trouver deux professeurs de lessin
industriel j'ai contacté dernièrement un
un jeune dessinateur de des cadres d'une
industrie de la région parisienne 32
ans il m'a demandé ce que je pis lui
offrir 84000 francs c'est le contrat le
contrat de de contractuel c'est la c'est
ce que je peux proposer dans de telles
conditions il gagne 1200 francs par par
moi alors évidemment la réponse est
venue tout de suite c'est non j'ai
personne
encore le recrutement la crise de
recrutement du personnelignant c'est
avant tout à mon avis c'est avant tout
une question de de traitement alors que
va-t-on faire maintenant et bien j'en ai
rendu compte et puis ma fois ben nous
cherchons encore je vais faire paraître
une une annonce dans la presse locale la
semaine prochaine pour voir si par
hasard quelqu'un susceptible de donner
un enseignement pourrait pourrait venir
comment envisagez-vous la rentrée
prochaine et bien la rentrée prochaine
sur le plan local grâce un peu au
concours des autorités locales nous
arrivons à trouver des solutions mais le
problème est grave tout de même même sur
le plan général parce que nous abordons
la montée des effectifs cette marée qu'
a connu l'enseignement primaire va nous
atteindre il faudra des mesures
extrêmement urgentes il faudra les
prendre sinon nous cour la catastrophe
courir à la catastrophe étant exclu il
nous reste à souhaiter après avoir
applaudi au fort du Loiret que soit
trouvés cette année les moyens et les
crédits nécessaires à la généralisation
de cette réforme de l'enseignement qui
devrait pratiquement doubler le
potentiel intellectuel et technique de
la France faute de quoi il faudrait se
contenter d'une bonne volonté générale
appréhension qui nous suggéra une
dernière question vous avez l'impression
que sans cette bonne volonté la réforme
de l'enseignement est impossible à
réaliser c'est incontestable est-ce que
ça n'est pas dangereux de compter
uniquement sur la bonne volonté des gens
je ne pense pas je demeure optimiste
[Musique]